[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation house our sound
thought okay how many people here use
Wikipedia routinely I love that breath
of air that comes up when you wave
around like that
truce how many here have not been to one
of these seminars about long term
thinking before have not been from the
audience that's a measure of the viral
nature of the internet because the only
way word gets out in these things is by
email so you either got email for me or
somebody forwarded it to you and that's
pretty interesting Wikipedia is some
kind of revolution in progress and it's
already yanked the rug out from a lot of
theories of human behavior and you know
that you know people only do things in
their own very personal interest and
some kind of phenomenon is going on some
kind of thing that people apparently
want to do with knowledge we didn't find
out until it was set in motion and so
please welcome the man who set it in
motion Jimmy Wales
[Applause]
thank you
thank you thank you so just a few months
ago I ran into Stewart and he asked me
to come and give a talk about vision and
I thought to myself well that's getting
to be typical these days even though I I
remember three years ago I was just this
guy in my pajamas at home typing on the
Internet and so now I'm asked to all
kinds of big-picture visionary questions
but the truth is I'm really more of a
carpenter than an architect I do my
practical work and it seems to work okay
but I got some thoughts about about
vision and the role that vision plays in
Wikipedia in 1962 Charles Van Doren who
was later a senior editor at Britannica
said the ideal encyclopedia should be
radical it should stop being safe but if
you know the history of Britannica since
1962 it's been anything but radical it's
still a very safe and stodgy old
institution Wikipedia on the other hand
begins with a very radical idea and
that's for all of us to imagine a world
in which every single person is given
free access to the sum of all human
knowledge and that's what we're doing
alia Mamadou Yolo knows something
Kyra wails my daughter wants to learn
I'll you though lives in Molly and Kyra
lives in Florida so we have a problem
but guaca-- who's a Wikipedia volunteer
is here to help so the point of this
story here
what guaca does he he goes in Molly out
to local people and he helps them write
articles in Wikipedia he speaks French
with them they speak French and Bambara
he types in to the Bambara Wikipedia he
translates into French and people
translate the articles from French into
English and thereby we're able to learn
things about local politics and customs
in that area the point of this is that
when we talk about our work in the
developing world we don't think of what
we're doing as building an encyclopedia
and you know here's something fancy that
some nice rich people made for
you instead we think about empowering
everyone on the planet to get involved
everybody to join that global
conversation so what is Wikipedia
Wikipedia is a freely licensed
encyclopedia it's written by thousands
of volunteers in many languages so the
thing that's really to me for an
audience like this everybody I'm sure
has used Wikipedia is that correct yes
yes when you've just seen Wikipedia and
you see what it's like and you just use
it as a reader you may not understand
some of the philosophy behind it and and
the freely license bid is one of the
most important things so what do I mean
by free
I mean free is in speech not fries and
beer this is an all say free software
movement and we basically what it means
is we give people four freedoms they
give you get the freedom to copy our
work you can modify it you can
redistribute and you can redistribute
modified versions and you can all of
these things commercially or non
commercially so when we talk about
Wikipedia being a free encyclopedia what
we're really talking about is not the
price that it takes to access it but
rather the freedom that you have to take
it and adapt it and use it however you
like and that's really really core to
our mission and it's really core to the
vision of Wikipedia that inspires people
to work so hard on them so how big is
Wikipedia
it's now extremely big we have the
English Wikipedia is the largest it has
nearly 1 billion words the this is
larger than Britannica and Carta
combined it's actually that's that's an
out of date comparison because it's
several times larger than Britannica
Canon Carta combined it's really really
quite a large body of work and the
German Wikipedia which is the second
largest is equal in size to Brockhaus
so how big is Wikipedia globally we've
got over a million articles in English
but one of the things that's interesting
is that English is less than one third
of our total work we're truly a global
project in many many many languages so
we have 380 thousand articles in German
over two hundred thousand and French
polish Japanese there's five more
languages that have at least a hundred
thousand articles one of the more
interesting ones is Chinese Chinese says
we have sixty two thousand five hundred
articles up until last October we were
not we were completely accessible in
mainland China and we've been blocked
since since that time I was just in
Taipei Taiwan last week and I met with a
bunch of Wikipedians there and it's
really exciting to see them working on
it of course Taiwan is not blocked so
they're able to keep working but one of
the cool things that's going on is that
the the the Taiwanese Wikipedians
communicate with the mainlanders by
Skype and they yeah by Skype so they're
all on skype together and they're
basically they're communicating
information to the mainland Wikipedians
about how to get around the blocks and
so about half we've lost about half of
our mainland editors but about half are
still coming in through various
mysterious means which are is really
cool to see this community coming
together to do that you know this has
been a lot in the news lately with
Google's new thing and just that in the
other one of the things that we say is
that Wikipedia will never compromise
with censors period
what this means is we're trying to get
unblocked in China but we have this very
firm position that our work is already
neutral that's one of the core values of
Wikipedia 99.99% of Wikipedia is of no
interest to the Chinese government you
know articles about the moon or Tigers
or whatever what they used to do is just
filter certain pages we wouldn't approve
of that but if they went back to doing
that that would be a lot better than
what they're doing now so we're trying
to get unblocked but we won't compromise
so we'll just see what happens we have
three and a half million articles across
200 languages so as I said English is
only about a little less than one-third
of the total work but saying 200
languages isn't really all that accurate
I don't like to really brackets and we
have 200 languages what we do have we
have 38 language versions of Wikipedia
that have at least 10,000 articles and
we have actually 85 now that have at
least a thousand articles so a thousand
articles is not really an encyclopedia
that's just the beginnings but I like to
monitor that number because that's once
we have a thousand articles I know
there's a community there there's five
or six people they're getting started
they're starting to build theirs
regulars there and that's when it really
starts to really starts to move
so how popular is Wikipedia Wikipedia
has become a real internet phenomenon in
the last couple of years in particular
we're now according to Alexa we're a top
20 website and we now have a broader
reach for example than the New York
Times so that by reach I mean the number
of unique IP numbers that we see in a
given day we see more people or more
people see us I should say than the New
York Times we see more people than the
LA times more than the Wall Street
Journal more than msnbc.com but the
really cool thing is we see oh and the
Chicago Tribune the really cool thing is
we see more unique visitors in a day
than all of these sites combined so
that's pretty good so these days when
people from the mainstream media call me
up I'm now I'm not one of the people on
the shortlist of if you're a journalist
these are the people you call when you
want to know what the internet thinks so
they call me up and they say what does
the Internet think and and what does the
Internet think of mainstream media and I
said you mean Wikipedia because you know
who is the mainstream media name or
we've got around five billion page views
monthly
say about that many one of the
interesting things about the way we're
organized as an all-volunteer
organization except we have three
employees we have a lead software
developer I have an assistant in the
office and we have a my assistant has an
assistant but we have there's a lot of
noise around me believe me we have all
volunteer developers and so forth and
the kinds of metrics that most people in
the dot-com in a top-20 website would
know like how many page views we have we
don't really need to know that we don't
have advertising or whatever so we're
really bad about gathering these numbers
I'm the only one who actually cares and
I only actually care because I'm coming
out and giving speeches so from time to
time I begged them to please tell me how
many page views and somebody grudgingly
goes and calculates it so it's about
five billion but I don't actually know
this little picture just shows the
growth of Wikipedia my favorite part
here is in in early December there was a
bit of a scandal you may have heard
about there was a apparently a mistake
in Wikipedia believe it or not and who
knew and the the media went crazy and
they called me on CNN to yell at me and
so forth and the net result as you can
see is our traffic almost tripled so you
know what are you gonna do so what is
the amazing technology behind Wikipedia
and and this is what I want to lead into
is is really one of the main themes I
like to hit upon the technology required
for Wikipedia is essentially you need a
database you need a web server you need
a web browser and you need the wiki
editing concept now the wiki concept was
invented in 1995 by Ward Cunningham
Wikipedia didn't start until 2001 so all
of the technology including the idea of
a wiki which is a website anyone can
edit has existed since 1995 why you know
why is if it's a technological
innovation then why not have it earlier
and the answer is it isn't a
technological innovation at all it's a
social innovation Wikipedia is a social
innovation in the sense that what we
figured out between 95 and 2001 was no
new technology we had the web and all
that stuff but basically the the basic
idea of how to organize a community what
are the social rules that you
one of the social norms values practices
that you need within a community and a
lot of that is that the design of
Wikipedia is the design of the community
some of the core features that really
make Wikipedia work are the free
licensing so everything is under free
licenses are really empowering to all of
the people working on the site most
websites when you visit the website
you'll see that the if you read the
Terms and Conditions they're really
abusive I mean they basically say
anything you enter on the website
belongs to us
sorry and people have put up with that
for a long time but it does discourage
people from feeling really empowered to
take control of a site and really care
for it whereas under the free licensing
they realize that hey if they if the
organization running this if the company
running this does a botched job we can
all leave we can take our content and go
it really does belong to us and also you
know if you're gonna spend hours and
hours and hours contributing knowledge
to the world I think it's really
important to have that feeling that it
will always be available lots of things
come and go in the world but as long as
you put it out there under a free
license that you've collaborated with
other people you know it will always be
there as a base for somebody to work
forward on so that's really important
there have traditionally been two views
of how Wikipedia works one view is that
Wikipedia is an emergent phenomenon
pseudo Darwinian so you'll hear a lot of
the phrases like the wisdom of crowds
swarm intelligence those kind of phrases
are very common hive mind but the other
view is that and this is my view is that
there's a community a community of
thoughtful users and that's what really
makes Wikipedia work
a former Britannica editor had a really
nice way of putting the emergent
phenomenon view he was writing a very
negative and critical article about
Wikipedia and he said sarcastically by
some unspecified Darwinian process will
assure that those writings and editing's
by contributors of greatest expertise
will survive articles will eventually
reach a steady state that corresponds to
the highest degree of accuracy does
someone actually believe this evidently
so well when I first read this I thought
you know that's really interesting
because within our community you will
only rarely or occasionally hear people
talk this way normally within our
community we're actually talking about
very old fashioned types of things like
references you know good writing
neutrality how
right things we're talking about
people's behavior in the community all
those kinds of things we're not talking
about some kind of magic process the
emergent model view would have us think
that Wikipedia is thousands and
thousands thousands of individual users
they don't know each other they each
contribute a little bit and somehow out
of this emerges a coherent body of work
it's like we're all ants right the
alternative view the view of a community
is that we are a dedicated group of a
few hundred volunteers we know each
other and we all work together to
guarantee the quality and the integrity
of the content you can see obviously
what my view is since I put pictures of
a bunch of my friends up on the slides
but when I first thought about this and
heard this I thought you know this is
really interesting because there are
implications for these two views
implications on how do you manage a
project like this how do you get
something like this to work if you
really believe in the hive mind type of
view
well individual users aren't that
important they're like ants in a colony
you can step on a few of them and it
really doesn't matter and the other
thing is that that you should have some
sort of metrics programmers always love
to have lots and lots of metrics like
the eBay rating system the eBay rating
system works really really well
because most of the interactions on eBay
are not necessarily community
interactions when I go to buy something
on eBay why do I care about that number
I care about the number because I don't
know that a person and I don't know
anybody who knows them all right and so
I need some kind of a metric and that
works very very well for a site like
eBay but in our case we don't have
ratings of users and the reason we don't
have ratings of users is that the people
who are working and together and editing
articles they come to know each other
and they usually become friends even if
they disagree very strongly they do
become friends or they at least get some
grudging respect for each other they
Duke it out for several months and they
come to some compromise the kinds of
judgments that we use to make the work
be good have nothing to do with rating
metrics and numbers I mean you can
imagine suppose you you went to work at
a company and every day you you have
sort of a badge and it has a number on
it that tells how many people liked you
or not right not really where you want
to work I think right instead what do
you want you want people to judge you
want a wide variety of characteristics
and that's what we do within Wikipedia
we have people
we say you know this guy does fantastic
work in biology but whatever you do
don't let him get near israel-palestine
he goes bonkers right so how do you
capture that in a number you really
can't capture that in a number it's it's
real human judgments about real human
people this person has you know they do
good work but they're difficult
personality all those kinds of things so
what is the vision in the software how
do we look at the software and how do we
think about making the software so that
people can do this kind of good work how
do we ensure quality so how does it
how's that actually work well there's a
lot of details to it a lot of details to
how the software works and I'll just go
into a couple of those but before I do
that I want to talk about my overall
philosophy of the design of social
software so imagine that you're going to
design a restaurant okay and so just
think about the problem of design for a
restaurant you want to design a
restaurant and you think to yourself
well in this restaurant we're going to
be serving steak okay and since we're
going to be serving steak we're going to
have steak knives and since we're going
to have steak knives people might stab
each other so how do we solve this
problem well what we're gonna have to do
is we're gonna have to build cages and
keep everybody in a cage to make sure no
one stabs each other right well this
makes for a bad Society we reject this
kind of thinking in restaurant design
and yo this is the predominant paradigm
for social software design what we do is
we sit down and we think we're gonna
design a website we think of all of the
bad things people might do and we make
sure that we have controls and
permissions everything to prevent people
from doing the bad things right and this
does this has two effects one effect the
first effect is when you prevent people
from doing bad things there's often very
obvious and direct side effects that you
prevent them from doing good things if I
look at a web page and I see a little
spelling error but I don't have
permission to edit that page I can't fix
it
right that's the first order effect that
by by having complex permission models
you make it really hard for people to
just spontaneously do good but the
second effect has to do with how human
interactions are organized how do people
feel of each other how do people feel
about society many many people report
when they've been involved in some
online mailing lists or things like this
that gee it's so hostile there's so many
hostile communities on the internet one
of the reasons is is that this kind of
philosophy of trying to make sure that
no one can hurt each other is actually
eliminates all the opportunities for
trust we had a situation in Wikipedia
where somebody proposed on the mailing
list they said well everybody has a user
page in Wikipedia and most people just
use their user page to put a picture of
themselves and some information about
who they are and it really isn't for
other people to edit so why don't we
just lock all the user pages right
because they do are subject to vandalism
and things like this well a lot of us
the old-time Wikipedians we went around
and we put little statements on a year's
lepage and mine is still there as far as
I know I haven't looked lately and it
says I trust you you can edit this page
but please if you do make it better do
something nice in fact there was a
picture of me that I hated it's been on
there for months and last night I went
to dinner with some Wikipedians they
took a picture a very nice picture and
now that's how my user page write and
yes he's sitting right out here and so
the that's the kind of thing that just
happens spontaneously and it couldn't
happen if we didn't have that culture of
trust to say yeah you know knock
yourself out fix my user page and if
anybody does anything bad we have the
real-time peer review so this is this is
into the nitty-gritty of how the
software actually works you know all the
good intentions in the world and saying
oh we love everybody and wiki love it
doesn't get you very far if you don't
really have the software tools to make
it really work so how does it actually
work
well some of the core components are
that every edit on the website goes
under the recent changes page and this
is watched by hundreds of people daily
so if anybody does anything bad on the
site it gets reverted very quickly it
gets reverted because we store every
single version of every article that's
ever existed so if an article is
deteriorated in any way and starts to go
downhill anybody can revert back to the
good previous version and they do that
by keeping an eye on the recent changes
and nowadays in the English Wikipedia in
particular but also in German and French
and Japanese the recent change has moved
so fast that it's really not practical
to monitor directly so within the
community people have built these cool
software tools to actually monitor
recent changes for various kinds of
problematic entries and things like that
and then additionally people can set up
their own personal watchlist so when
you're editing a Wikipedia article most
of the power users have it set up so
that anything they touch I don't know if
it goes on their watch list so you can
you can fix something in Wikipedia and
then you can keep an eye on it for
several days you can come back every day
and you can see if anything has changed
and you can actually see you know how
that works and then another element of
it is is the real-time communication so
we use IRC which is Internet Relay Chat
this is very old-school chat rooms
predates Instant Messenger it looks like
this it's sort of ugly but there's
there's tons and tons of people we have
I'm not even sure how many IRC channels
we have we have them in many many
languages in fact the reason that the
Chinese use Skype instead of IRC is that
IRC is blocked for a meal in Chinese so
the entire Chinese I always wondered why
I could never find any Chinese people in
IRC and the reason is they're all on
skype instead so this was just a
screenshot from just the other day and
as you can see just on a random morning
there were 238 people sitting in the
English Wikipedia Channel so at any
moment in time when you're on the
website and you do something if you
start misbehaving yourself 230 people
are gonna hear about it pretty quickly
and they're gonna come in and they're
gonna start watching you normally we
have policies of we try not to bite
people so first we leave you a nice
message saying you know thank you for
your [ __ ] you comment but we're trying
to write an encyclopedia
after a little bit though you can get
blocked the admins can block IP numbers
for misbehavior and and that does happen
then when you look at the page history
our software is a really nice compared
to a lot of wikis although a lot of them
are getting nicer nicer of course we
have a really nice comparison between
the old version and the new version so
if you think about how could I monitor a
long article I would have to read the
whole article every single day that
isn't what you really have to do you
just come in and you look at the changes
and you see did this change improve the
article or did it make it worse and you
can see that at a glance in most cases
and so if this is one of your articles
that you keep an eye on you would come
in and you say oh yeah this this said
it's good this one I don't like so much
I actually think I can do something else
and you can just continuously keep
improving it another key feature and
this goes back to this goes back to the
the whole restaurant analogy is that we
have hard core we have organization by
the community so one of the just to give
an example of this we have the articles
for deletion pages so the idea of the
articles for deletion page is that
occasionally articles new articles get
created and they need to be deleted so
what why would you ever delete anything
there's lots of disk space
the simplest example would be something
like someone makes an article with the
title of asdf asdf and the the text of
the article is hi mom well when that
happens probably that's never going to
become and it's like Lapita article you
know you can think about it for a minute
and say yeah I don't really think that's
ever gonna be an encyclopedia article in
a case like that that would be a speedy
delete any admin could just come in and
delete it it would just it would just go
like that but there are other cases
where it's borderline where you might
say I'm not sure if this is a hoax is
this real is this not real and the
example here was a film called twisted
issues an obscure underground punk film
from 1988 the funny thing is I gave a
talk just two days ago at the University
of Florida in the next day somebody
wrote me and they said do you know I
played on the soundtrack for twisted
issues wow really go go ahead at the
article please so anyway some of the
first person says it's supposedly an
underground punk film but it miserably
fails a google test so what's the Google
test you look something up in Google and
if you can't find it then it probably
doesn't exist
it's this is not a foolproof test but
it's pretty good right there are still a
few things on the planet that are not in
Google but it's it's pretty good and so
it fails the Google Tasks you know it
doesn't have any any listing so a couple
of people say delete delete and then
somebody says hey wait wait wait I found
something it's in the film threat video
guide to 20 underground films you must
see so maybe it has some notability next
person down says to clean it up somebody
says keep it's a real movie it's an IMDB
keep-keep so at the end of a discussion
like this this would have been kept in
fact it was kept in the article still
there but the interesting thing about
this process is that although people are
voting delete and keep right this is
just a wiki page like any other this is
just freeform text you can go and click
on edit a top of the page you can change
this you can add a comment whatever
there's no actual automation of the
voting process and this is one that's
always popular with programmers who say
no this is a lot of work why don't we
just put a little button on the page
nominate for delete after two weeks we
tally the votes and it'll automatically
gone that's not a good idea because just
voting is something that we don't do
very much we really discourage voting
this is a human dialogue this is a
conversation about whether or not this
should exist or not and in fact in
theory this could be 28 votes to delete
and 3 votes to keep and as long as the
the the deletes are all like delete none
notable delete none notable with no
information or argument these three at
the bottom who say wait I found it in a
book maybe people didn't realize this I
know something about it it's actually on
IMDB that would make a big difference
the other thing that can make a big
difference here is who the voters are
we're we're a community where we
generally know each other we recognize
names we can see people I can say okay
look Rick K says keep it I trust Rick K
for K says it's an IMDB it's an IMDB I
don't have to question that whereas some
of these other people I I just say but I
don't know who they are
really they're newcomers and so certain
people in the community do carry more
weight than others so the most important
thing though about this is that all of
the rules are social the software itself
does not determine the rules of
Wikipedia almost everything is
completely open-ended in terms of what
the software does there's very very
little in the software that is actually
rule enforcement it's all about dialogue
it's all about conversation it's all
about humans making decisions so that's
really really important so what comes
next what am i working on next is what
I'm actually going to tell you about and
what I'm working on these days is
wikia wiki is a new company and
basically what we're doing at wikia is
we're bringing the community ideals the
community models all of the things that
I just talked about in relation to
Wikipedia we're bringing to a broader
context so one of the conceptual ideas
is to think about that an encyclopedia
is big right it's a really big set of
books but a library is much much bigger
so what we're trying to do is empower
people to say let's think beyond the
encyclopedia let's think about all of
the different kinds of things that
people might want to build or do what
made me think of this why don't we want
to do this well I have certain beliefs
about genuine communities and the future
this is where I want to talk about the
future of free culture one of the things
of course that's going on in our society
is this struggle between you know
proprietary and free culture and so you
have things like the battles going on
about copyright in the movie industry
and this and that one of the things that
makes me really proud about Wikipedia is
we're starting to change the terms of
the copyright debate we're starting to
change the terms and say look the
copyright debate is not all about kids
stealing music when when the law gets in
the way of Wikipedia's work it's about
good-hearted people sharing their work
trying to do good things and if we have
these really restrictive copyrights it
gets in our way it not only gets in our
way but it isn't necessary I mean the
standard argument for really strong long
copyright terms is you need it in order
to economically incentivize people to do
good work well Wikipedia proves that
isn't true people do good work because
it's the good thing to do thank you
so my idea now is okay we've got this
first big shining example but let's
build this out into a much bigger
cultural force let's make this let's
take these ideas of Wikipedia and bring
them out to lots and lots of people and
lots of lots of areas far beyond just
encyclopedias I think that genuine
communities like Wikipedia will be built
on love and respect I get a lot of talks
at tech conferences and I always like to
say I'm the only guy who's gonna get up
at a text conference and talk about love
right but it's really important because
of all the things I've been saying
Wikipedia is not about the technology
it's about people it's about leaving
things open ended it's about trusting
people it's like encouraging people to
do good that these communities I believe
are going to be the norm on the Internet
I think people have seen that some of
the old models are really unhealthy they
really don't work and I think that
Wikipedia shows us a really powerful
means to move forward to empower lots of
people to do good work cooperatively
that people when they're empowered by
the software and they're set free both
by the license but also by the the terms
of the site and the way that it works so
that they're free within communities
decide their own rules and think about
this they can do great things and so
we're really looking at what are all the
kinds of great things that people can do
so a lot of people say well an
encyclopedia covers everything so what
else do you really need and so I wanted
to give some of the examples of the
things that we're seeing so far this is
the the lost wiki I did do people here
watch the show lost lots of people a few
people you should watch it it's really
great but it's really really really
complicated and there's lots and lots
and lots of characters and it's really
hard to figure out and the cool thing is
the lost wiki the fans of the show are
coming in and they're documenting all of
this complicated information so you can
go in here and you can read about this
this is far beyond what you would want
an encyclopedia for one thing second
it's not necessarily neutral the people
who are writing the site are fans of the
show so they don't need to be neutral
they don't need to include criticisms
and controversies about whatever they
may choose to but they don't have to it
can be a very favorable review because
it's written by fans who really love it
these are the kinds of things that
people can do and build in the old days
when if you think back on the old geo
cities days and lots of people were
building fan pages and things like this
but what would happen people build a fan
page and after a while they get bored of
it it's really not that fun to do all by
yourself the idea here is people can
take whatever passion or hobby or
interest they have and they can build
something they're gonna give
a free license and they're gonna come
together with love and respect and build
all kinds of cool things on any kind of
topic so we have some of the most
successful things we have so far of
course geek culture so things like Star
Trek Star Wars is a doom wiki you can
see the the this little picture here on
the search box the guy looks a little
angry I don't know if they really know
about the wiki love idea here but they
seem like nice people and then so there
is one that does cover wiki love this is
the the personals personal stuff wiki
accom one of the cool things about about
my job is that if you found an
encyclopedia you somehow get this
reputation of a guy who knows about
everything right so tonight I'm gonna be
on free FM I'm going to be talking about
personal ads and dating on the internet
why me I don't know but I'm gonna talk
about it and I'm gonna talk about the
personals wiki and the idea here is
there are all kinds of personal sites
and how do they work well they work you
think about those software principles I
talked about earlier they think of all
of the bad things people might do and
then the software doesn't let them do
that whereas the idea here is let's be
free-flowing and let's let this
community think about it and work about
it negotiate and figure out how would
you properly do it as a community what
are all the kinds of things you really
want to do and the software is really
open-ended so people can form whatever
they like so I think it's really has
great potential anyway we'll see what
happens
and so this then brings me to my final
point which is my my basic philosophy is
for us all to make wiki love not war
thank you
so I guess now we're gonna have
questions yes please okay good
is it Illiana street waving a hand back
there very short question very readable
in the dark thank you how do you make
money oh well
Makia is one way Wikia is the model for
Wikia is we're a for-profit company
supported by advertising Wikipedia works
really well as a non-profit because
people are very passionately
enthusiastic about this idea of a free
encyclopedia for every single person on
the planet so even our servers are
managed by volunteers there are people
who stay up I know one of our admins
stayed up 26 hours as a volunteer when
one of the database servers went down
stayed up fixing it well we don't expect
that people are gonna do that for things
like the personal site or for the lost
wiki or things like that it doesn't
quite have that instead what we want to
do is provide the infrastructure through
the for-profit and through the
advertising revenue one of the things
that I just recently joined the board of
Creative Commons and one of the things
that Creative Commons thinks about a lot
is okay we all believe in in free
culture right we all think that sounds
like a great thing let's be
non-proprietary let's share how can we
make this work right how how do we make
this work so with free software this was
this was the question for many years
well where's the business model where's
the business model
well now finally we begin to know the
business model there are several you
know there's Red Hat there also
incentives for companies like IBM to
contribute they have incentives for
whatever reasons for consulting for
hardware sales things like that so we
know the free software sustainable but
what about free culture so one of the
things that I'm really interested in
doing is helping people think about how
do we make money how do you make a
living I mean it's great to say yes
let's love the world but we have to
think of ways to make it sustainable and
ethical and non proprietary so that's
that's what I'm doing these days well I
have a question I read online that you
were influenced early on behind Rand who
you know based everything on selfishness
and knows peed on any kind of altruism
what
think she would make of all this and are
you consistent with your early
enthusiasm everything's changed
I'm not sure what she would think of all
this that's a very difficult question my
views haven't really particularly
changed so I think that a lot about her
views are widely misunderstood if you
approach it in a very simple way if you
remember one of her one of her great
characters that everyone remembers was
Howard Roark he's the architect and he
he was offered the opportunity to design
buildings for a lot of money but he had
to compromise his artistic principles
and he refused and he went to work in a
quarry instead and so the idea that
passionate self-interest has only to do
with thinking about how to make money is
really not correct for me passional
passionate self-interest has to do with
having a vision sticking to it and so
for me I'm just doing something that I
believe in and if I make money that's
great if I don't hey whatever at least I
did something I believed in so I know
what the first line of your bio
somebody's biography of you will read
it'll say Jimmy Wales laughs hard work
laughed as the beginning of the fountain
good yeah I was it was either that or
petrograd smelt of carbolic acid which
is from one of her other doesn't quite
have the same Flair but Walter Cox has a
question where are you right in here
what keeps a political entity like the
People's Republic of China from
corrupting an article like Tiananmen
Square massacre it seems to work now but
for how much longer you know the site
specifically on that this raises the
question the Burning Man that everybody
keeps running into you know what we'll
time due to this beautiful vision and
what will how can it possibly scale
doesn't it get dirty when it gets to a
certain size right yes so those are
those are similar questions was slightly
different so the question is what about
an organized group coming in and trying
to do something in Wikipedia well the
first answer is that the community that
we've built has pretty strong right and
the way things work it would be pretty
easy for us to say you know you can't
just come in and replace it with a
one-sided rant or whatever that will
that's gonna work really well and in
fact one of the things that I would say
is that if the Chinese government would
like to come and contribute to Wikipedia
they're free to enter
dialogue like anybody else but they're
not gonna be treated in any special way
so they may not be able to get as far as
they would like the I didn't go into all
of the details of how the communities
organized but I can tell you like one
one story there was a case where a
neo-nazi website on the internet with
message boards they discovered Wikipedia
and they said oh this is this whole
thing is terrible it's a big Jewish
conspiracy they have pictures and they
were measuring my nose to see if I you
know it was really crazy and so they
said well they discovered the votes for
deletion page which is what we used to
call it now we call it articles for
deletion for very complicated reasons I
can't explain but they said oh there's
the votes for deletion page we're gonna
go in and we're gonna delete we're gonna
take over Wikipedia we're gonna delete
all the articles we don't like so they
went in they didn't they went in they
said well we're gonna nominate this and
were gonna vote it to delete they said
there's 40,000 members of this website
we can easily overtake them right so
they all came over all 18 of them right
that's not see math 40,000 18 so all 18
of them came over and voted so that
particular vote ended up being like 85
to 18 and they didn't succeed but people
in the community said well what would we
do we do have this open process and I
said well that's us this is still my
role in the community we have consensus
we have democracy we have this and that
but we still have a little bit of
constitutional monarchy and so I said
you know my role in the community is to
defend the community and so one of the
things we would say is well if a bunch
of Nazis come and try to take over the
site I'll just ban them that's easy and
due to our current existing rules allow
us to do that well know other than the
rule that says comma unless Jimbo
whatever you know and the but the key
there is that that requires a certain
amount of trust and requires me to not
do that basically and I never do that
you know go in and ban a whole large
group of people would be one of the most
shocking events that ever happened in
Wikipedia but I think it's been
important that we keep that kind of
thing so that we can experiment we
freely experiment with our institutional
structures and we don't have to be
paranoid it goes back to the restaurant
analogy we don't have to say any we're
designing a voting procedure we don't
have to think of all the worst-case
scenarios and design for people stabbing
each other we can assume the best
then we can also know that if it doesn't
seem to be working out the core
community can just say yeah if we'll do
something else so that's that's one
answer the end their answer let me stick
with that one from because it the
Emperor issue is an interesting one
mm-hmm
I've run into it with the best magazines
are often run by as they say a mad monk
at the middle somebody who's you know
that's all you and they're they're very
good at it yeah in a sense you're
infallible as Pope races acquit it
sounds like the way you're describing it
is you're an emperor who is ultra
powerful but not always right in
summation was how the I was the social
house the social apparatus able to help
you realize when you're wrong and let
you undo something that you did even
though your Emperor well the core
community really runs things on a day to
day basis and so while they would
respect a decision to ban a bunch of
Nazis if I started banning a bunch of
Republicans they would freak out right
and it would be a huge global news story
and I'd be on CNN and they'd be yelling
at me again and but this is one of the
concerns we've had and actually one of
the this is part of the whole process in
the very early days we really did have a
benevolent dictator model and we had it
for the same reason that a lot of free
software projects have it is that when
you're trying to get things done rough
consensus running code you don't want to
get bogged down in formal
decision-making processes and so what do
you do you just say well you know
Linda's Torvalds gets to decide at the
end of the day and that works reasonably
well but I feel that's a very deeply
inappropriate for all human knowledge
that's something that I don't like to be
and I don't like to do and so over time
as the community has grown we've been
growing institutional structures within
the community so that less and less has
to do with me so for example in the old
days I used to do all the banning to
actually you know if somebody's really
misbehaving they can be blocked or
banned from Wikipedia I did all of that
it started getting too much for me but
also we realized that it isn't really
appropriate for one person to have that
much power so now we have the
arbitration committee and this is
elected from the community and it works
really well the arbitration committee is
a very thoughtful group of people they
have
very strong support from the community
one example - village was elected with
like 95 plus yes votes - no votes so we
sort of maybe Cuba style elections but
but they're actually genuine that that
this is the process and that people
really do support because they pick you
know the the kindest most thoughtful
people in the community who are really
good at mediating conflict and trying to
find some middle ground and those people
do a good job of very carefully
considering things and you know there's
always problems but the goal over time
is for for me to move from benevolent
dictator to being like a constitutional
monarch right I gave a talk more I went
into this in Germany and then the the
next day in the newspaper it said I am
The Queen of England it's not exactly
what I said something was lost in
translation but the idea is I should
have certain theoretical power for a
while now but they should be decreasing
over time and and that ultimately that
power should go away and be nothing more
than symbolic so are you working on your
regal wave interrupted you and you're
talking about scaling the other part of
the question was scaling what how do you
as the community gets larger and larger
how do you how do you deal with the with
the issue of scale and there's a few
problems and in fact something we talked
about we had a long conversation about
it at dinner last night so I I told you
the story of articles for deletion and I
said well 26 people could say one thing
and three could say the other and if 30
had better arguments they would prevail
well that's actually not true it's
mostly true
but recently articles for deletion has
been very problematic because there's so
many people there that it's become very
difficult to identify the three people
you trust the three best arguments and
so that's the scale issue and and it
works when there's smaller groups of
people because you can trust and you can
you can negotiate you can compromise you
can come to a consensus with a really
large group it's a lot harder so one of
the ideas that was proposed last night
which I've been thinking about all night
is this for example take that portion of
the community where things have started
to scale too big and break it down into
smaller groups and to basically say
you know within the individual area of
expertise so if the article is about a
bridge then the the wiki project for
bridges should be the ones deciding the
deletion because that's a small group of
people again now you're back to not just
one person but 20 or so people who could
get in there and actually negotiate and
compromise and actually think about it
in a better way so that's some of the
things that we're looking at but we're
very aware of this issue of as the
community gets larger and larger how do
you keep parts of it from becoming
unhealthy and moving that thing to sort
of the subgroup does that happen in some
way automatically is there somebody
handling traffic it's it's nothing
happens automatically so everything in
Wikipedia the way things change over
time is a very long and slow process of
negotiation and compromise making an
example showing people that it will work
persuading people one at a time this is
also one of the big misconceptions about
Wikipedia I mean it's a wiki right
anybody can go and change anything
anytime and so the idea that people have
in in the press and things like that is
that it's complete chaos all the time
and everything's gonna change randomly
from one day to the next but in fact
inside the community we're very very
conservative and very old-fashioned
things change at a snail's pace things
that work we love them and we keep doing
them until we've completely smashed our
head against the wall and then we start
to slowly change things in a different
way so it's a long very fluid process
well that's the example of the American
Revolution they they were very radical
and they were very conservative the way
they did it unlike the French Revolution
which was radical and radical the way
they did it and they wound up killing
each other right be conservative yes
question from looks like and Schumann
ants human somebody oh great thank you
how do you distinguish the experts
experts from the amateurs and I think
this anticipates your answer what is the
future of the experts well so a big part
of the the idea how do you separate the
expert from the immatures that ends up
being a really just a human judgement I
mean one of the things that we don't do
is check people's credentials and and
all that what I always like to describe
it as it's rather than having a
keeper model we have an accountability
model so we don't put up gates and say
well first you've got to show us your
PhD car before you can edit instead what
we say is everything you do in the
community is easily with one click you
can see all of your contributions and
people can see what you're doing
so you're accountable for what you've
done and so how do you judge who's an
expert or who isn't well it's the same
way you judge it anywhere you did so a
long process of getting to know someone
and see if they know what they're
talking about if somebody posts a bunch
of crap every single day it quickly is
out and people will say this guy post
crap every day and somebody who does
good work gets recognized for that in
terms of what's the future of the expert
you know I think one of the interesting
things about Wikipedia is how much of a
meritocracy it ends up being that if
people are willing to cite their sources
they're willing to be very careful in
their argumentation they were willing to
write neutrally and calmly their writing
survives if they come in and post wild
speculation and they can't prove it or
it's just some random rumor it doesn't
survive and that's truly what we want
out of our experts anyway there's a
question in dear to our hearts having to
do with digital preservation how is
Wikipedia being preserved in or archived
by the way will it be around in 10,000
years
that was from a camera in the sadi sorry
back so the the very first basic simple
question is we do backups actually we
actually backup from the main cluster in
Florida to our cluster in Amsterdam
that's done periodically we do periodic
database dumps which lots and lots of
people reuse and download the the only
bit that we that we really have to be
very careful about is the the user
database the user names and passwords
because those are not distributed
publicly all the content is truly so we
have to be extra careful to make sure
we're always backing up that because if
if we lost the text of Wikipedia there
are thousands of people who have a
fairly recent copy so we could we could
upload and lose a week's work or
something like that we'll Wikipedia be
around in 10,000 years so obviously the
idea of an of the organization lasting
that long is a little far-fetched
and hard to imagine it's kind of hard to
design an organization that would last
that long in terms of the
decision-making that I do and that we on
the board do at the foundation we really
think very carefully about survival
we're very conservative we don't borrow
money for example we're strictly on an
all-cash basis we we think very
carefully about as we do different
things we think about what is this going
to do to our monthly revenue
requirements and is that always
something that's very comfortable so
that we're survivable we don't want to
take any risks
another example along those lines of a
decision we've made print-on-demand
publisher came to us and said they had
this really cool software that you could
we would be able to construct lists of
articles and print you could just click
a button and you would get a book in the
mail of Wikipedia articles well this is
sounds great I mean technologically it
sounds great but there's a big
difference
legal difference between being online
and being in print online if you've got
if you've got libel or a copyright
violation somebody complains there's
provisions in the law digital and
Copyright Act you take it down and
you're pretty well protected you have
certain responsibilities as soon as you
print it right it's a whole other world
I mean it's there's a big legal risk
there so this error that we had back in
December well when the fellow notified
us that we said he had something to do
with the Kennedy assassination boom it
was gone it was deleted in five seconds
and that was that's actually what makes
it possible if we were legally
responsible for everything everyone
writes on the website well the whole of
the internet couldn't exist I mean it's
impossible for anyone to provide an open
space for a public discussion if you're
responsible for everything everyone says
I see what you mean about you're
changing the discourse and copyright in
the course yes but when you when you go
to print though if we did that we would
get sued and we would lose and so we
can't do that until we really think
about how do we mature community
processes so that we can identify enough
materials that we can say this is safe
enough to go to print it's it's been
through a process that's industry
standard or better so here's a middle
ground question from anonymous if you're
anonymous wave your hand
my friends in Africa don't have good
internet access yet will there be a DVD
box set of Wikipedia and win yes we
already have there's a German company
which produces German DVD they take the
legal risk in that particular case and
we there are a lot of projects to to
create DVDs we actually have still
online we're still not comfortable
distributing it offline ourselves but
online we have database dumps that you
can burn that you can download fully
runnable this is an area that we're very
keenly interested in going forward I
mean the community we really take
seriously and it inspires a lot of us in
the community that our work is not just
for people with broadband internet
connections we really want our work to
be useful and have an impact in places
where people don't even have good
drinking water that's one of the reasons
that we insist on everything being
freely licensed because we want to make
sure that anybody out there who has an
entrepreneurial idea a small-scale
entrepreneur can go out and actually say
hey I see an opportunity here to print
encyclopedias for kids in India right
and I can make a buck doing it and that
sounds great to me I would love that I
mean you can't you can't hardly think of
a better way to make a living right then
providing low-cost books to children and
the cupboard if we had if we allowed
things in the site that were for
non-commercial use only it would prevent
that and so that's one of the
interesting things people always say I'd
love to donate a bunch of stuff to you
but I don't want people making money off
of it and this is my answer
well is it that you don't want people
making money off of it or is that you
don't want people making your work
proprietary and then usually people see
the light see what I'm talking about
well that relates to I supposed Nikolas
Nagar parties hundred dollar computer
notions some of we some people don't
like it some do of which camp are you in
I hope he builds that it sounds cool I
need one this one costs way too much you
know he's got a Macbook duo here yes yes
yes so by the negroponte he goes around
saying he wants to get a hundred dollar
computer out so everybody in the world
can get Wikipedia yeah yeah no I know
and
gladdie says that because I agree with
him that that in many ways Wikipedia is
the killer app for that kind of device
because if you think about a hundred
dollar computer that's gonna come with
you know some basic software what our
people are really gonna use it for well
it has wireless so they can start using
for communication but one of the really
cool things is instant access to the
world of human knowledge through very
low-cost means I'm very excited about it
and you know I have no idea I'm not at
all an engineer so is he
tilting at windmills I don't know but it
seems promising anyway question from
Ellison fish right down here if your
editors all know each other how do you
keep a check on the sometimes polluting
power groupthink yes well that's a very
interesting question as it turns out as
we get bigger and bigger unfortunately
they don't all know each other but there
is a very strong tight-knit community
and that is in fact a danger it's one of
the things that we really try to be
aware of and a lot of our social rules
have to do with that there are a lot of
things that we do this is this
particularly comes into play when you're
thinking about the administrators
administrators are elected from within
the community and they have certain
powers but they're they're more like
police than than feaf domes right so
they yes they can block you from editing
just as yes the police can arrest you
but police are very constrained they're
only supposed to arrest you in certain
circumstances they can't just go
randomly go around arresting people
administrators for example are not
supposed to use their admin powers and
anything that they're actively involved
in editing so if you've been editing an
article you get into a quarrel with
someone and you just say well then I'm
gonna block you that's deeply
inappropriate and you can be you know
DISA soft for that but it is something
that we're very aware of and we always
try to say one of the most important
values that we have as a community that
I think is really important for us to
keep is the idea of always being welcome
to newcomers and always be welcome to
two outside ideas and perspectives but
of course as an any group of should be
more about that how do you actually do
that because I've seen a lot of things
including things I've run
the whole earth became a small community
and we started shutting out new people
and we died how do you welcome new
people um well a lot of its really just
very practical stuff if you start
editing Wikipedia someone you know make
make 20 or 30 yet it's hopefully sooner
than that
somebody will show up on your talk page
and say hey welcome to Wikipedia here's
some links hopefully when it's done well
when people have enough time they'll
actually have looked at your work and
they'll say I noticed you editing the
train area have you seen the wiki
project trains right and and they'll
actually greet you in a personal way and
there's people who love doing that and
it's a really important part of the
community as long as we keep those kinds
of habits I think that's that's part of
it I mean that's that's actually a great
example of you know it's one of my
ongoing themes is battling against
programmers right programmers say well
gee we you know it's a lot of work you
have to go and find people who have
edited ten times and post this stuff on
their page and we could automate it on
your tenth edit you automatically get a
welcome message right it's so much
easier right but it's there's no human
there right you know so so we don't do
that right we just said we don't
algorithm algorithm it ties things that
don't need to be but ya know I at a
certain level I think there is no magic
answer to this problem it's a problem
that all human organizations face you
know how do you really make sure that
you've got somebody with an outside
quirky point of view that you're
actually trying really hard to
accommodate them as best you can and you
really try to work with them to say okay
well let's you know we don't agree with
what you're doing or trying to say but
we're gonna try like where can we
compromise where can we come in and say
you know what can we use out of what
you're doing and you may not get
everything you want keep in mind right
as long as we keep that up we're doing
okay but there's no magic guarantee I
mean it's it's eternal vigilance is the
price of Liberty well the and this is a
coupla culture issue in a way to
constantly welcome people or not and do
you make that explicit or is it
something that's just constantly done by
example and therefore everybody knows
that's the way to do it it's a bit of
both
it's a bit of both it's it's very
actively written about and talked about
is
as a core value don't bite the newbies
is one of our policies you know a
question from Scott which apparently
were getting lots of versions to this
question where's Scott in back what is
the size of a Wikipedia's infrastructure
the physical systems and by the way
what's your power bill the the size is
about you know yay big it's no I'm just
kidding we have right now around
we just got 40 new servers so I think
that we've just passed 200 servers in
service worldwide the bulk of those are
in Florida where we have I was just
there the other day and I counted the
rocks but I forgotten I think we have 7
full racks if that means anything to you
in Florida we have servers in Amsterdam
we have servers in Paris but just a few
and we have some servers that Yahoo
provided for us very nicely in South
Korea so that's what we have Pat hunt
with a question I have an addictive
personality where are you Pat we own
cedar uh-huh
his involvement and Wikipedia editing
dangerous to me yes yes although I mean
I I'm I always say I'm really an
Internet addict but at least I've turned
my addiction for the good of the world
somehow yeah I mean people do get really
into editing Wikipedia and that can be a
good thing if a lot of a lot of really
great work is done by people who are
some kind of borderline obsessive
compulsives right now you joke but it's
actually true that there are people who
really like organizing things right and
they come in they organize organize
night after night after night and they
can become very obsessive and that's
fine it can be a fine outlet if you you
know if it's something is itching you
and you want to scratch it and keep
doing it that's fine the the problem can
be is if you get stressed out right and
and so people sometimes get very
stressed out by Wikipedia a lot of
people who are who have those kind of
personalities they do really great work
but they're they can be quite brittle
meaning if anything doesn't go right
they get really upset and it's very
difficult for them and so that's
unfortunate
you know it's it's other than carpal
tunnel or something like that it's not
inherently unhealthy well we all
remember that one of the founders
creators of the oxford english
dictionary was say he was in an insane
asylum yes yes with lots of time on his
hands a little pair of related questions
one from henrik back over there and one
from rolf somewhere henry Cass did
banning anonymous users from starting an
article do any good and rolf asked I
noticed that the authors of an article
are not easily visible can you explain
why these authors aren't more interested
in getting credit ok so what are you
referring to is a very minor policy
change got a lot of news because it
happened coincidentally around the time
of the signal fail or incident and what
we did was if you're an anonymous IP
number meaning that you haven't logged
in you're unable to create a new article
you can still edit just about any other
than the main page and a few articles
it's possible to go to Wikipedia you
don't even login you just click it and
you save it goes live on the site
immediately and it shows up as an IP
number but you can no longer create new
articles did it do any good I don't
think so it didn't seem to help and so
we're probably going to change it again
very soon what we really are trying to
do there we we get I don't know the
exact numbers recently but we get about
5,000 new pages created a day of which
only 1500 survive the other 3,500 are
people experimenting or their deliberate
vandalism but that's not as common as
just people are trying the system out
and they create a page by accident
sometimes people create a page that's a
duplicate of another page and it needs
to be merged just has a slightly
different title things like that a lot
of that kind of stuff goes on but it's a
huge firehose of stuff coming at people
every day 5,000 articles that have to be
dealt with and the idea was let's just
slow it down a little bit it turned out
what happened was it slowed it down a
little bit but what it really did was on
that page you were forced to create an
account so then people just started
creating thousands of accounts per day
people who never became members of the
community so it didn't really do the
right thing what we really want
instead is a better way for flagging new
Venus of edits so we want to be able to
not prevent newcomers from doing things
but we just want the community to be
able to see them in the smaller wiki's
that's pretty easy if you're working in
you know a smaller language where
everybody still kind of knows each other
you can just look at the the recent
changes and you can see after a couple
weeks of experience here and now this
person this who's this is somebody new
I'm gonna go check out what they're
doing now in English there's so many
people editing that it's even for
somebody who's deeply immersed in the
community there's lots of experience
Wikipedian so you just happen to have
not come across yet so it gets it's a
little harder to judge when you see an
edit is this done by a known and trusted
Wikipedia nor is this somebody who's
totally new the community who may not
understand our values yet so in that's
the direction we're gonna move is
basically better tools for identifying
that this person is kind of new we want
to make sure we do that in a way that's
friendly and supportive not the same
problem we talked about earlier of is
this the first step in excluding
Outsiders by marking them with a little
flag or something well this relates to
the question of credit because there's
no way us customers go on there and you
know when I read things in the newspaper
online I look at the byline and it often
influences my you know whether I'll keep
reading in a big way you don't have by
lines and the articles and but yet
within the the regular user group as you
were saying some people have their
opinions have more value than others
because they've earned that right well
what do you think about this in terms of
publicly visibility of people so if you
go to any article and you click on the
history tab you can see all of the it's
you can see all the authors one of the
things I think we'll probably want to do
and this is actually one of the things
with we're very excited about in the
nonprofit we rely all on volunteer
programmers right and so a lot of
features of usability that we've wanted
for a long time we just didn't have so
now I'm hiring right so if you want to
be involved in this at wikia if you're
if you're a good PHP programmer web
experience things like that we're
basically going to try to add a lot of
features to the software
we're hiring a team out here in the Bay
Area to add feature so one of the
features that we want to add is when you
click on an article right now you can
see the entire history but you can't see
who wrote what it's kind of hard
you also can't see who wrote the largest
amount of the article who's the most
active users some of the articles have
10,000 edits and you can only see the
last hundred right you can keep paging
through them but to really figure out
who wrote it and who's responsible for
it we want to be able to sum that up and
I mean somebody showed me a demo of this
but and I was very excited I'm like yeah
we'll run this and he said well it's
actually just a mock-up great idea but
we need somebody to actually code it so
if there's anybody in the audience who
wants to be one of those coders who do
they get in touch with and you can email
me and I'll put you in touch with them
personally so so for for this kind of
thing what we want to do is is think
about what are the kinds of tools that
that will enable us particularly as we
grow to to in in line with our
philosophy in line with the principles
that we have to say okay well one of the
things that makes Wikipedia work is that
people know each other well what are the
areas in the software where it makes it
hard to know who did what right and so
to say okay well one of the things when
I go as an editor and I say this is a
great article who's responsible for this
I want to go to a click and see oh 78
percent of this was written by so-and-so
so I could say that this is a good
editor I can even go thank them and say
that was a great article why do people
not want credit right on the article
page right that was a part of that
question and I think thinking about
those kinds of motivations or what
people care about is lots of different
people have lots of different reasons
some people probably do want that kind
of credit but they don't get it so
either they don't work in Wikipedia or
they just come to live with it but I
think the main reason is the general
public who's coming to Wikipedia we
don't know who they are or do we you
know we don't necessarily even care so
much what does matter to people is is
recognition by their peers and so if I
write an article and it's really good
right and I'm really proud of it and
some very prominent well-known Wikipedia
in like mine spilitt who won the
election with 95 percent if she comes by
and says hey great article I'm like this
is great you know I this is somebody I
really respect and so she cared about it
so that was really good so I think
people
care more about recognition in that
sense rather than that some million
people I don't even know happen to see
my name on a page and they'll never
remember it how does that recognition
get around is that through the IR seen
it through the RC a lot of it's just
through the active editors I mean if
you're really active in editing people
tend to cluster in areas of interest so
if you're if you're a part of the bridge
wiki project and so you're working on
articles about every suspension bridge
in the world other people who are
interested in bridges will get to know
you and they'll see your work and
they'll say this is really great work
and they'll appreciate that and so
that's it's it's because I think the
idea is there's the large community
right but then there's a large number of
sub communities and as long as those sub
communities are all healthy then then
that's that's where it comes from
way to go I'm gonna finish up with two
questions here one from Jed Harris who's
out there somewhere
aside from encyclopedia vendors printed
encyclopedia vendors who are your real
enemies enemies I mean I ran to oz wrote
great enemies with great name yeah no I
mean it's hard for me to think that way
and that's part of the reason why I am
Who I am right I'm not that smart really
but I'm really friendly so are there are
their institutional enemies out there
things that are sort of standing in the
way of the Wikipedia's ation of
everything yeah I mean there are there
are certain things like you know I think
that I'm very concerned about software
patents right but as far as I'm able to
tell patent policy is mostly driven by
the pharmaceutical companies right and
they've got their whole set of interest
which I have no knowledge about I have
no really strong opinions about but when
when their lobbyists are influencing
patent policy and it spills over into
the software world in ways that are I
mean whatever you may think about the
fundamental issue of software patents
certainly you can say there's better in
worse ways and deciding what we need to
do about software patents should
probably be decided in the software
world not having to do with the needs of
suitable research right so those are
things where you get really irritated at
certain institutional structures I think
you know a lot of things that sort of
annoy me are things like the proprietary
scientific journals so I'm a big
advocate of the open access movement and
public library of science for example
and they're doing these you know
peer-reviewed very traditional
peer-reviewed scientific journals but
they're putting them under Creative
Commons licenses and so that people can
distribute it and they're working on
finding different business models the
traditional business model of scientific
publication is a pretty good one right
if you can get the work because you
don't pay the scientist anything and you
saw the journals for a lot of money
right this is a great business right it
isn't necessarily healthy for science it
isn't necessarily healthy for the
developing world for the for humankind
in general but it's a it's a model that
used to work it used to be the model
that made sense it made sense because we
thought well gee distributing all this
stuff is very expensive well now we know
distributions free you know so there's
no inherent reason why if someone in
university in India that's not well
funded wants to read some scientific
paper well I mean just download it off
the internet I mean it's really cheap to
provide it it's just we have these
institutional structures that don't want
that to happen for very dinosaurus
reasons right so those kinds of things
sort of irritate me but I think that
that's just a matter of time as people
discover the new ways and I think all
that's going to change there's someone
here from the Public Library of Science
tonight I believe senator Barbara's here
there she is how do you do
last question from Gary wolf Gary where
he is I'm impressed that this has been a
wonderful wonderful thank you talk about
design in one of the squishiest areas to
design in which is social stuff and
community stuff so Gary's question is a
good one to end on what are the unsolved
problems of Wikipedia right I think the
the really unsolved problems are the
ones that are facing the
english-language Wikipedia
terms of scaling the community there are
a lot of areas where in these really
large communities and and there's
English is the largest by far the
English Wikipedia community where we're
bumping up against interesting kinds of
barriers like for example you know in my
talk I have this happy story about
article stir deletion when in practice
we know it isn't working as well as it
used to that lots of times what happens
is people don't know each other there
and they're really voting and Outsiders
come in because of somebody sent around
a hundred emails and they all rushed in
to vote and people don't quite know what
to do about it those kinds of areas are
the real challenge whereas if you look
even at you know the German Wikipedia
which is the second largest but it's
still in terms of the size of the
community it's where English was a year
ago right and so we've got another year
of experience of getting through those
growth hurdles and then the really small
ones I mean this is where I love working
with the small Wikipedia is because I
you know I was just in in Taiwan like I
said I met with the the Wikipedians
there and they're at about 65,000
articles and their communities of a
certain size and they're facing you know
they have these difficult problems but I
know how to solve those because I've
helped several of the groups come
through this process so I always worry
about what's next right and English the
English Wikipedia always pushes those
boundaries first so I think it's dealing
with the scale that's really the
unsolved problems is is going forward
we've managed so far and I hope we
continue to but it's you know it's a big
deal let me finish mmm this audience is
probably interested to hear about your
other audiences and what we were driving
over you told me that you just talked to
1200 people in Taiwan and also had a
high old time talking to students at
University in Florida you want to say
something about what you got from those
audiences yeah well I mean it was really
interesting when I was in Taiwan I I was
recognized on the train for example
right and that was kind of cool and it's
actually funny because the the Wikipedia
viewership per capita viewership is
about 50% higher in Germany than in the
US right so and I'm in the media all the
time in Germany and so I always say I'm
like David Hasselhoff
really big in Germany but the what what
I really get and then and then in in
Florida it was like these are these are
all the college kids know everybody's
using Wikipedia they're all really
excited about the possibilities of free
culture these are people who have now at
this point you know they're beginning to
be the people who've really grown up
with the internet right and whereas for
us it sounds really you know bizarre in
certain abstract ways that the record
companies are all wound up about
file-sharing to them that seems really
really weird right because it's always
been that way right and they're just
like what are the people talking about I
mean they're really and so but they are
they're very interested in in the these
questions and and also interested in the
idea that a lot of this stuff it's not
about kids stealing music it's really
about creative people it's about the
producers not the consumers and so
that's some of the things I get out of
it I
the thing that I really get out of mmm
I'm I traveled I travel all over the
world is really one of the things that I
always enjoy is sitting down with a
group of Wikipedians and talking about
Wikipedia and realizing that you know
the Hungarians when I was in Hungary
they just had their first real incident
where they had to ban someone right
there at about at that time they were
around fifteen thousand articles
normally between 10,000 and 20,000
articles is where they come the
community has their first really hard
ban it's for the community if somebody
just comes in and starts vandalizing and
causing trouble that doesn't cause the
community any problem you just block
them and who cares right the the problem
users the ones who are really hard are
the ones who they do good work right
they're kind of okay but they're really
jerks right and what do you do they've
got their friends they've got their
enemies they're starting to and some
people are very manipulative and so
they're turning factions and the
communities have to get through that
hurdle and say what are we gonna do here
and they eventually they have to say you
know we're sorry but we appreciate your
work but you can't keep behaving this
way and we're gonna ask you to leave the
community and that's a very emotional
process for people but
it's the first time because in the early
days it's all very ideal it you know you
get a whole bunch of good people
together you've got eight or ten people
all working everyday and you get to know
each other maybe up a few quarrels but
it's all okay so this happens again and
again everywhere I go you know it's the
same stories and there's something to me
that's really wonderful to know about
that that as much as there are cultural
differences there's also you know humans
are humans and we have the same kinds of
problems and joys and loves and all that
everywhere so here here thank you very
much for Wikipedia and for the talk
[Music]